At first glance, I knew we had
a beautiful sign here in the making.
It's definitely a restorable piece.
My name is Howie Cohen,
and I run a sign company
in Utica, New York,
called Just Neon Sign Co.,
and I've been doing this since 1993.
The techniques are the same.
The equipment has gotten a lot better.
There are more gauges,
there's more analytical data
that we can obtain when we fill the signs,
but essentially the whole process
is entirely the same since the beginning.
This particular sign is
a Hudson Automobile sign.
Hudson was a very popular
make in automobiles
back in the '40s and '50s.
They're no longer made,
but these signs still exist
and are highly desirable
amongst the collectors.
Signs of this nature at auction
could bring upwards to $20,000 to $30,000.
My only task here is to restore the neon.
The dealer that had this sign
brought this sign to me in
the condition that it is in,
and I took it upon myself then
to restore the sign using
the original materials
that were used back in the 1940s,
which is neon tubing.
When a sign comes in, the first thing I do
is I make paper patterns of
the neon letters to be made.
Once the tracing paper
is attached to the sign,
a black marker can be used
to outline the beginning
and the end of each letter.
The interesting thing about making neon
is we do everything in reverse.
So the pattern I make
here has to be reversed
before I begin making any neon.
The most challenging part
of making a good pattern
is making a good tracing.
You have to make sure your
pattern is not going to move,
that your paper is not going to move,
and it's got to stay that way
through the entire tracing.
The holes where the glass
housings are located,
if they're off a little bit,
your neon unit that you
install might not fit,
and that would mean
that you have to do the
whole thing over again.
Once I have the pattern
made, I can measure out
how many feet of glass
I'm going to be using.
The glass tubing that we use
is specifically made for
the neon-sign industry.
It comes in various diameters.
This particular one is 12
millimeter in diameter.
If you use a tube that's too large,
you lose some of the detail.
If you use a tube too small in diameter,
it would require lots of
transformers to power it.
We use a carbide-tip circle cutter
and a Dremel tool.
With those two tools,
you can make nice, smooth, accurate cuts.
With my fires on, my glass at hand,
I'm going to be shaping the glass.
It takes many years and years and years
and miles of glass
before a glass bender could be comfortable
with making letters.
The type of glass we use
is a relatively soft glass.
The fires we use, either
the long ribbon burner
to make gentle arcs and curves
or the sharper cannon fire,
which is used to make what
we call double-back bends.
The glass will soften,
and then you really have to
apply a little bit of air
by way of your mouth
into the glass tubing,
which will then keep it round.
The hose that's in my mouth
is called the blow hose.
Without the blow hose,
it'd be very difficult
to put the proper amount
of air into the glass
as it's softening.
If you don't do this, it will crimp,
and the gas and the electricity
will not flow properly.
The biggest challenge of
the glass-bending process
is not to get burned, not to get cut,
not to burn and then cut yourself,
or cut yourself and then burn yourself.
Everything is a challenge.
There's so many things that
can go wrong in making neon.
Once the glass is bent, it
goes to the bombarding table.
The machine you're seeing is a manifold.
This meters the gas into the tube
and evacuates the tube,
and that's where all
the oxygen, water vapor,
impurities are pumped out.
The glass is also heated.
It's heated to a very hot temperature.
Upwards of 300 degrees C.
Very hot.
Once it's that hot,
almost all the impurities
are pumped out of that tube.
Then the gas is filled.
Once the gas is applied to
the tube and filled properly,
a high voltage can be passed through that.
The high voltage excites the gas,
and in this case it's argon.
There's also a little drop of mercury
that's added inside the tube
to make the glass fluoresce.
When it lights up the proper color,
then you know you had no
leaks and you had no issues.
Every neon sign is composed
of a tube sealed at both ends.
These ends are called electrodes.
It's a metal-to-glass seal,
which allows the electricity
to go inside the tube.
Once the tubing is done,
it's time now to mount it on the sign.
The sign is a porcelain sign.
It doesn't need painting.
It's actually a glass material
that's put over the top of steel,
is actually the surface that
was put on back in 1940.
There are small tube supports,
and then these little wires
are just twisted tight.
That's all it takes to
fasten the neon to the sign.
What I have here is a light socket.
In the industry, it's
called the glass housing.
This is placed inside the sign.
The metal ring is then
fitted onto the threads
and tightened down.
When the neon sets in there,
it just makes physical
contact with that spring.
Inside the sign,
there is a 15,000-volt transformer
powered to 110 primary.
That's a lot of voltage,
but the current is very low.
It's only approximately 30 milliamps.
It won't kill you, but
you'll know it's there.
I installed the glass
housings, the tube supports,
the wiring on the inside,
and the transformer,
including the power cord and switch.
There's nothing more that makes me happier
than to take a piece of history
and bring it back to
the original condition
that it was maybe 70 years ago.
This is the way the sign
came out of the factory,
and this is the way it's going to be kept.
I'm really happy with the
way this thing turned out.
The colors are right.
They're nice and bright.
Everything is uniform.
This sign is going to
be a beautiful addition
to the museum of the car collector.
This is a great example
of a double-sided porcelain sign
with the theme of automobiles.
In this case, the famous Hudson.